we're bringing you all the tips and
tricks to get a head start on your
spring cleaning is there two sexier
words i don't think so
and speaking of spring cleaning i gotta
jump on mine already
that's right this is me tackling my
lovely little old pre-war coat closet
and i'm trying to
not only control something that i can
but i'm trying to organize so that my
mornings when i'm getting my kids ready
run smoother um so i wanted to
try to organize because i believe that
organizing
sets you up for a better life a
healthier life
a smoother life and a general happiness
that money can't buy
and we want to see how you organize so
if you don't mind share your pictures
or video using the hashtag
organizewithdrew and who knows
we may feature that on the show i had a
lot of girlfriends
sending me like their lego organization
it was really fun i think this is a very
inspiring thing that a lot of us can
relate to
again it's something we can control and
i am so excited because we truly have
the icons of organizing
right here on the show
they work with people like um let's see
reese witherspoon
the kardashians gwyneth paltrow and they
have
huge collaborations with people like
target
and the container store they have two
new york times best-selling
books and a binge-worthy netflix series
okay
you guys literally it's the home edit
and they rule the school when it comes
to the declutter kingdom
just take a look we are professional
organizers and have teams all throughout
the country it's legally blocked
oh my goodness and look at all these
drawers that have all of her accessories
i know
she elle is living her best life with
her organization
i'm excited to see this what
you guys how did you do this in a couple
hours oh well
did you just eat look
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome the clean queens of the
home edit clea shearer and joanna teplin
[Applause]
i was very excited to see what your
backdrop was gonna be
and of course it's like clean serene
and very organized well i i hope it
didn't disappoint
so i mean we really worked hard on it
you never do
and i want to ask how you guys met
where you met and how you decided to
team up
sure okay so this is my specialty yeah
so it's an excellent telling story i'll
take it away
um so joanna and i met in august of
2015. um
we were introduced by mutual friend i
really wanted to start a home organizing
company
joanna used to have one in san francisco
and our mutual friend knew this
and said you guys should meet up at
least talk yes
i was like all gung-ho about doing this
together joanna was like absolutely not
never no way
anyway we ended up going to lunch we sat
down it turned into a four-hour lunch we
just got up as business partners and we
went into business that same day we
designed our logo
we got our domain our social handles we
came up with our name we started our
paperwork it was just
yeah pretty much right from the minute
the minute we sat down
we were both just had this like light
bulb moment where we just both knew this
would work
it was just one of those bizarre i don't
know not love at first sight because
we're
we're not married to each other or
anything like that which is a common
misconception
we do have other husbands but we are
kind of married also right but it's just
it was sort of that intuitive like
yes this is my person to do this with
and i
immediately felt it and i guess we felt
it too and we just what she's trying to
say is that i was right
if that's what she was trying it's the
only time she's ever been right though
so you know
i can't tell you how excited i was to
hear this story first of all i was like
what is the origin story of the home
edit again it's like it's never not been
here
but i feel like you are one unit with
two great individuals and i was curious
of the origin story within the origin
story
of the roy g biv strategy the rainbow
effect where did that come from
well i mean i just want to say i was
rainbow bright
uh for halloween for like six years in a
row when i was a kid so it's
really always been deep in my soul but
the rainbow really represents what the
home edit is about
it's marrying form and function the
rainbow
is essentially a system of
labeling just it's just a visual label
so you know
if you line up clothes and rainbow order
the blue goes in the blue section the
red goes in the red section or
like the books behind me um and you know
it's lining things up in a system
but it's also really aesthetically
pleasing and visually beautiful which is
basically our entire goal setting up a
system making it look beautiful i love
that you bring function to it
and i'd love to ask you what is one of
the biggest mistakes as we speak
throughout the hour
that people make when it comes to
organizing
all right well we have a few i mean many
i mean how much time do we really have
the first thing well people don't start
so i think they look at their house and
they think that they're gonna they need
to tackle the whole house
in an afternoon and then they get
paralyzed and they just don't start so
that's
that's the first mistake they make is by
not starting the second mistake i would
say is that they start too big yes
you cannot start with a closet or a huge
kitchen or a large pantry or something
that's
an overwhelming yeah an enormous project
you need to start with something that's
very small that you can see the entire
process through a to z
get very comfortable with the process
and then extrapolate those steps out to
bigger projects as you get more
comfortable
absolutely totally great now it's spring
cleaning season
and you guys just released this amazing
book that i've been carrying around with
me in my
backpack um it's i'm not kidding it's
the home edit workbook
and there's just an amazing way to
fill things out incredible guides
make lists it's room to room it's so
brilliant what gave you the idea to do
it in this unique format
so we wanted to create a workbook spiral
bound
you can write in it scribble in it
sketching it drawing it
that really allowed people activities
and prompts and thought starters and
you know all sorts of things to get
people to just dig in right so the
workbook is really designed to be
our kind of hand-holding and a gentle
nudge uh again room by room
the other thing that we have is the gold
stars
we have a whole page i'm sure drew you
saw this but we have a whole page in the
front of
stickers of gold stickers because as an
adult no one is giving you gold stars
anymore and why is that
right we were like no we deserve a gold
star yes who doesn't need a gold star
there's no age too old for a gold star
correct
no absolutely not
[Music]